翻訳: Hiroko Kawano
校正:
みなさん はじめまして
菊川惠です
突然ですが 今から約9か月前
こんなニュースがあったことを
覚えていますか？
2014年2月25日
ある父親が逮捕されました
自分の３歳の息子を
首輪で窓につないでいたそうです
首輪の長さは約１メートル
鍵の高さは 子供の身長よりも
高い位置にあったそうです
男の子は身動きをとることが
できませんでした
このニュースを聞いて
みなさんどのように思いますか？
テレビではこんな声が
たくさん流れていました
子供を愛せないんだったら
最初から生むんじゃない
父親失格だ
私は心が痛くなりました
傷ついている子供を知ったことは
もちろんですが
それより 過ちを犯した親に対しての
社会の目はこんなにも厳しいんだ
と思ったからです
そして 自分自身が加害者に
なってしまう可能性もある
その思いが私の心を苦しめました
自分の将来に思いをはせた時
私はこんな社会で生きていくことは
できない そう思いました
私の中学時代の話をさせてください
「親は子供を愛するものなんだよ」
「お父さんとお母さんに感謝をしましょう」
「命はとっても大切なものなんだよ」
優しい顔をして近づいてくる大人は
そう言いました
そして みんな口をそろえてこう言いました
「今はわからなくてもね
大人になったらわかるよ」
頭ではちゃんと理解できました
でも 心の底から理解することは
できませんでした
中学生の時 家に帰ると
いつも同じような光景が広がっていました
床の至る所に物が散乱した部屋
カビだらけのお風呂
洗っても洗っても
山のように溜まる食器たち
美味しそうなご飯は親と兄妹のもの
いつも私のご飯はありませんでした
ため息をつきながら掃除をしました
よく見てみると
死んでいた状態で生まれてきた兄の遺灰が
ガラクタの中に紛れていました
中学2年生のとき ある朝起きたら
母は亡くなっていました
その母の遺骨も箱に入ったまま
長い間 部屋の隅に放置されたままでした
私の家では 命は粗末なもの
だったんじゃないか
そう思いながら
中学時代を過ごしてきました
命は大切なものだって
一つだって無駄な命はないって
頭では分かっていました
けれども 大人達が言うその言葉は
全部
口先だけの言葉に聞こえてしまいました
そして 心を閉ざすようになりました
自分の感情を殺し
自分の話をしなくなりました
痛みも 悲しみも分からなくなりました
自分が今何を考えているかさえ
分からなくなりました
そして 押さえ込んでいた思いは
自分の中で留めることができず
行動に出始めました
中学校を卒業し
だんだんと大人に年齢が
近づいていったにもかかわらず
恋人との距離のとり方が分からず
クッションで叩きつけてしまった
こともあります
動物が大好きだったはずなのに
かまってほしそうに近づいてくる猫を
足で蹴散らしてしまったこともあります
本当は人と仲良くしたいのに
近づいてこようとされると
連絡を取ることを急に止めてしまったり
目を合わせることすら
止めてしまったこともあります
全部大好きなはずなのに
どうして大切にできないんだろう
どうして自分の思いと矛盾した行動を
とってしまうんだろう
あるとき はっとしました
私は大人に近づくにつれ だんだんと
親に似た行動をとっていたんです
親を反面教師にしようとして
ずっと生きてきたはずなのに
親と似てきてしまっている
自分がいたんです
自分が怖くなりました
もし自分が将来 親になったとき
子供を苦しめる親に
なってしまうんじゃないか
そう思ったからです
そんな悶々とした思いを抱えながら
二十歳になりました
大人の仲間入りをしました
「子供の頃 辛い経験をした分
人に優しくなれるよ
だから頑張ってね」
と言われてきました
でも 私は優しい大人にはなれませんでした
そのとき こう思いました
もしかしたら 大人も
痛みを抱えているんじゃないか
悲しみを抱えているんじゃないか
そう思ったんです
ある日 「アダルトチルドレン」という
概念に 私は出会いました
アダルトチルドレンとは
子供の頃の家庭での経験や親子関係が
大人になってからも精神面や生き方に
あまり良くない影響を
及ぼしていることを指します
私はその概念を知ったとき ホッとしました
ずっと自分を責めてきていたけれど
大人だって完璧ではないんだ
ということを知ることができたからです
そしてこうも思いました
もしかしたら私の親だって
完璧ではなかったのかもしれない
はっとしました
私は自分の親に理想の親を押し付けて
親を親としてしか
見ることができていなかった
そう思いました
もしかしたら 親だって
痛みを抱えているのかもしれない
親だって悲しみを
抱えていたのかもしれない
そう思うことができました
でもやはり 私自身が親になったとき
子供を傷つけてしまうんじゃないか
という不安がありました
子供の頃は たくさん同情されたり
優しくされたりしてきました
でも もしも私が子供を
傷つける親になってしまったら
その瞬間に立場は逆転して
しまうんだろう そう思いました
たとえ 子供に愛情を注ぎたいと
思っていたとしても
親と違う子育てを選択したいと
そんなことなんてお構いなしに
批判をされてしまうんだろう
そう思っていました
アダルトチルドレンという概念を
調べていくうちに
自分自身の抱えている痛みを
緩和することができること
親と違う子育てを選択できることを
知りました
そして私はアダルトチルドレンの
克服方法を探し続けました
カウンセリングやワークショップを
たくさん見つけました
でもどれも高額で
私の手には届きませんでした
自助グループというものも見つけました
自助グループというのは
同じ痛みを抱えた者同士が集まって
自分自身の経験をシェアすることによって
心の傷を癒していく という集団です
でも 私が見つけたものは
神様や自分を超えた大きな力に
頼るものが多くて
難しくて なかなか足を運ぶことが
できませんでした
そして 途方に暮れてしまったんです
どうして家族という
こんなに身近な問題のはずなのに
身近な場所で 問題を解決できないんだろう
疑問に思いました
もっと身近に 自分の問題を
解決できる場所があってほしい
そう願って 私は もっと気軽に
自分自身の経験をシェア
できる場所をつくろうと思い
「はじめの一歩」という場所をつくりました
それがちょうど一年前の今日です
一年間活動を続けてきて
気づいたことがあります
実は その場所に足を運ぶこと自体が
ハードルになってしまっている
ということです
私がつくった場所に足を運べる人
というのはどこにでもいける人だ
そう思ったんです
ワークショップやカウンセリングのような
専門的なものは 社会には必要です
でも それが専門的であるが故に
ハードルが上がってしまっている
という現実があると思います
専門性は時に 人とは違う という
抵抗を生んでしまうんです
だからこそ どれだけ人に寄り添った
素晴らしい制度をつくっても
そこから取りこぼされてしまう人が
必ず出てきてしまうのではないか
私はそう思いました
途方に暮れている人や
痛みを抱えている人が
求めているものは
専門的な治療法でしょうか
それとも自分を救ってくれる
制度でしょうか
もちろんそれらは社会に必要です
でも 私はこう思うんです
本当に苦しんでいる当事者が
求めているものは
ただ受け止めてもらえること
ただ理解してもらえること
それだけではないか
そう思っています
身近なところにそういうものがないからこそ
専門的なものに頼るしかない現実が
あるんだと思います
そして 専門的なものに
ハードルを感じた瞬間
途方に暮れてしまうのは
身近な人に理解してくれる人なんていない
そんな前提があるからだと思うんです
だからこそ 私は今 この場を通じて
痛みを抱える大人がいるということを
知ってほしいんです
そして 子供を傷つける親を見た時に
少しだけ想像力を働かせてほしいんです
もしかしたら この大人も
痛みを抱えているんじゃないか
悲しみを抱えているんじゃないか
そう思って
批判することを
少しだけ躊躇してほしいんです
ただ知ること 躊躇すること
それだけでは何も変えることはできない
そう思うかもしれません
でも私はそうじゃないと思います
知ること そして
想像力を持って相手と向き合うこと
ただそれだけで苦しんでいる当事者は
あなたに理解してもらえていると
感じることができます
それだけで救われる人がいます
ここにいるあなたも誰かの居場所に
なれるかもしれないんです
知ろうとすること 想像力を持つこと
それが当たり前になれば
どんな社会になるでしょう!
きっと 今よりもカウンセリングにも
行きやすくなるし
身近な人に相談もしやすく
なるんじゃないかと思います
そして自分が思うような居場所を
選択することができるんじゃないか
と思います
居場所の選択肢が多い社会の実現が
結果として 巡り巡って
悲しい思いをする子供や
痛みを抱えている大人を
減らすことに繋がるのではないでしょうか
私は 自分を受け入れてくれる
人たちに出会い
少しだけ 居場所ができました
私には実家はないけれど
立ち寄ることができる場所ができました
帰る場所はつくれること
頼れる人は自分で選ぶことができることを
知りました
そのことが 今の私を生かしてくれました
ここにいるあなたも
私を生かしてくれた中の一人です
今まで私を生かしてくれた皆さん
ありがとうこざいました
これからも
誰かの居場所になってください
ご静聴ありがとうございました
(拍手)